well we've got four children one is an
adult now actually yeah yeah there's
very little we can do as parents that we
accept that but with their three younger
children we have limits on the amount of
time you can be on screen it's not easy
to enforce I'm not pretending is I think
it's not for any parent the younger the
I think that slightly easier but we also
have some other rules in the Javits
household so you can't take your tablet
or if you have a phone or any device to
your bedroom at bedtime and they have to
be left in the kitchen and we've got
charging points there and just leave
them there and I think that's one of
them actually the biggest points of
danger if you look at where children
have been abused and grooms often when
they sort of they feel they're safe and
secure in their bedrooms but actually
they're not because they're online we do
find it hard and you know how convincing
children can be yeah I mean have you
banned them from anything like Instagram
as you said times and when they can well
we and we go by the age limits so if
it's my ten-year-old you know for
example and she won't be on Instagram
and some of these things that have age
restrictions as they get older I think
that you have to I think try to manage
it as best you can is that I want them
to benefit from the online world and I'm
the first to admit there there are many
benefits from social media other sort of
online apps and things and I don't even
mind them playing the old game you know
I understand that of course that's that
there's lots of good things but I'm
really worried especially with what I've
seen now is home secretary about the the
danger that lurks online and like anyone
I want to protect my children but also
as home secretary I want to help protect
everyone's children that's what this
action is about that so given that
what's the time scale on this regulator
coming into force
well we so today is what's called a
white paper which is a consultation that
it will be for the next 12 weeks as we
do with any consultations but I think
that because there's a good but I take
cross-party agreement in Parliament
which helps especially when you've got
our hung parliament to to get
legislation through I think it come come
sooner rather than later now I don't
want to say exactly when if you've got a
deadline like this year and I would like
to see certainly progress this year
we've already said for example the sort
of codes of conduct we would expect the
future regulator to how
those published this year at least in
draft form but I think it's actually can
have an impact a lot sooner than that I
wonder if you can give me some kind of
thresholds on certain things so when for
example would have fine be necessary
when would it be actually you're going
to hold an executive criminally
responsible and when do you remove a
website altogether well I mean first
things I think to point out is that you
with this new statutory duty of care
we're proposing the the enforcer of that
will be an independent regulator it's
very important it's an independent
regulator because politics should have
nothing to do with this so the right way
to do things I just want to sort of like
a rough idea of what you think would
constitute a fine well I think if you
get the first of all it has to be
related to the seriousness of the
offense and I think also you'd have to
take into account how companies react
when that is pointed out to them but
absolutely if you have companies that
don't seem to be taking issue seriously
they're not reacting in whatever what
anyone would consider reasonable time
you would expect the railay to start
thinking about fines those fines to be
meaningful must be related to the size
of the company the bigger your turnover
the more I would expect that fine to be
and I think you would as a regulator
sort of work down that scale ultimately
if you have a company or website just
refuses to comply or you can't track it
down and then there are some companies
that will actually just make it hard for
you to track their management and things
ultimate sanction the regulator will
have is to block that website in the UK
some of the companies like Google have
massive turnover turnover hundred thirty
six billion last year now on data
protection the the is about four percent
fine potentially four companies are you
talking about that sort of level because
that that could be billions of pounds
it's wrong for me now to say your
percentages and things I would just say
to the social media companies that are
listening that these fines could be
significant of course it would be
proportionate it'll all be done in a in
a in a proper balanced way but if you
are a large company you can expect to
have significant vais you mentioned
Christchurch YouTube and other channels
try their best to take down that content
as quickly as they could
did you I mean obviously it was horrific
material but do you think there were
some channels that were criminally
irresponsible in the way that that was
dealt with or would it under this
regulatory new system would face fines
for what happened there
first of all with Christchurch I think
that certainly I think there were some
channels that did take it seriously
enough and it didn't put enough effort
into taking down some of that abhorrent
material especially the video of the the
live streaming of the of the terrible
massacre there's a 17 minute video and
they could have done more but also what
really troubled me is afterwards when I
spoke to the companies and I spoke to
something in Paris last week at the g7
is that they told me that they hadn't
really sort of prepared for a live
streaming event over of a terrorist
incident and I found that quite shocking
you know just about six months ago I was
talking about the live-streaming of
child sexual abuse which sadly has grown
and grown and how could these companies
not thought about the live streaming of
a terrace event and they claimed last
week that's what caught them off-guard
and I just find that really hard to
accept that if you were taking this
responsibility seriously why not already
as an industry there's already a body
that we've helped to set up which is the
global internet forum on terrorists
content and I've been to some of their
meetings and their job is to think about
things and think ahead and the fact they
have never thought of this just tells me
that there's much more work to do with
four days from possible No Deal brexit
given the choice between No Deal and an
extension and a long extension which do
you choose well I think they're on this
the PM had no choice because of the
parliamentary process that we've seen in
the last couple of wheels reduce it's
not it's not about it is it's it's it's
actually the Parliament has already been
very clear I think voting maybe on three
occasions now that it won't accept a No
Deal and because in our Parliament has
this ability which we are seeing play
out today actually where it can pass its
own legislation without the involvement
of government and if Parliament passes
legislation
man's government to do something because
that's the law of the land the
government has to do that so it's not a
choice that's being on the table it
hasn't been there for a while what I
want to see is Britain leave with a
sensible oddly deal I do think that is
still absolutely within our reach but
what we need is more parliamentarians to
come together and accept that the right
thing to do is to leave the European
Union and honor the referenda would you
be talking to Jeremy Corbyn in this
stage fewer Prime Minister well I I'm
being led by our prime minister and I'm
fully behind her decision I think she's
been put in a very difficult position
she's tried everything up until now in
terms of trying to get her deal through
but when the numbers just don't stack up
in Parliament I think it's right that
she speaks to parliamentarians
regardless of which party they're in and
tries to reach a consensus so that we
can deliver on the referenda that's
what's most important some say as Home
Secretary with wind rash and stop and
search and things like that you've been
clearing up after Theresa May do you
fancy the same job in number 10 I've
been getting on with my job in the Home
Office and you can see being Home
Secretary it's a there's a lot of things
that to do at all time something times
things can come and surprise you but
it's a job I still feels a huge
privilege to have and there are many
challenges like today we've talked about
the social media companies and their
responsibilities dealing with serious
violence having a sensible immigration
policy I'm just feel really privileged
to have when you're all out having a
crack at the leadership I I'm just
focused on my job as Home Secretary I
think that's what that's what's right
for the country is what's right for me